this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisements suck and
minimalists hello everybody welcome to
the middlemost podcast we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less
my name is Joshua fields Milburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist Ryan it is an election year
yes it is who you going for worse Daffy
Duck or Jimmy Carter I can't decide you
know every year is an election year
that is true and we talk we always say
it's an election year
but is it no matter when you say that
it's typically true you're usually going
to be voting for something whether it's
City Council or or something Allison
ours is not a a partisan talk show
everyone I think knows this who listens
regularly but today we are going to
discuss local national and international
politics so we thought we'd bring
someone in to do that we're going to
talk about the outrage and divisive
nature of our current political climate
we're gonna talk about how we can avoid
getting caught up in the disarray and
turmoil created by tribalism and
partisan politics and we're gonna do
that with today's guest Kim Iverson is
here today she's from the Kim Ireson
show can you for being here thanks for
being here Kim thanks for having me now
let me let me ask you this Kim we often
say well we don't want to get political
and that really frustrates me because
the the the word politics comes from the
word that you're the the Latin word that
just means the affairs of the people or
the affairs of the city and so if we're
talking about politics isn't I think to
some extent everything is political I
think what we're really talking about is
I don't want to be partisan because I
don't want to offend other people Yeah
right yeah I mean obviously everything
in life and for especially right now is
political I think everything's political
I don't think there's anything that
isn't anymore and so yeah people don't
they just don't want to they don't want
to make enemies or actually right now
though I feel like people are more
inclined to just say you know what I'm
gonna tell you what I think and I don't
care and if you're not on my team then
we can't be friends so I'd write I'd
rather suss it out right now anyway
that's what I'm kind of I'm noticing
this isn't it's quite a problem though
by its so exclusionary in a way where
it's like hey if you don't fit into the
same boxes mean fact we got some
questions that sort of dive into this
fact why don't we go ahead and start
there because we've got some really good
questions that I think will allow us a
jump off point to discuss some of these
political topics our first question is
from Christie in New York City I'm
wondering if you've ever discussed
minimalism for government particularly
interested reducing government cost I'm
wondering if you should really spoken
about that new governing system so
minimalism and government our minimalism
and in politics and when we talk about
minimalism Ryan and I are talking about
living a meaningful life with alas it
usually starts with the stuff then it's
about being more intentional with all
other areas of our life right and and so
people often think it just has to do
with material possessions I think it's a
big piece of it but a lot of has to do
with too much spending living beyond our
means etc well who's the most notorious
for living beyond their means and I
whether you're Republican Democrat
independent it's often the government
the government's often spending money on
things we don't want them to spend money
on however I think that's why it's
important to to find the right
leadership that we can have people in
place who will spend the money on what
we want them to spend it on
it's very libertarian right to say that
let's be minimalist with the government
less government very libertarian
viewpoint and yeah I mean for sure what
we want
I guess it really kind of depends those
who want maybe larger government and
more government spending but they want
it on things that are valuable to their
lives things that benefit their lives so
it does become a problem when you start
to look at government say wow they're
really spending on all of these things I
don't even know what that's for
you know like recently on the ballot
here in California there was this like a
measure to add money more taxation for
improving the schools the buildings or
something along those lines and you know
a lot of people are standing there
looking at this thinking gosh we've got
so many other things that we need this
money to go towards and yet we're just
adding money to the pot spending it on
all these random things and so you
you know I do think that people want
even people that want big government I
think what they wanted is to be
efficiently big government yeah and so
they still want that almost minimalist
attitude of well what are we less and
funnel this money into these select
areas that are going to benefit our
lives and then you've got the obvious
like the true minimalist for government
right we would be almost like an
anarchist yeah its inner when I think of
a minimalist government because when we
talk about minimalism it's really about
living intentionally and what you're
talking about as far as how the
government spends money that's what I
think of when I think of a minimalist
government
I don't think of less government I will
be the first to admit I hate regulations
but guess what we got to have some
regulations in place we have to have
people in place to enforce those
regulations so you know as a minimalist
I don't I don't think it would be
totally insane it's not like if we were
minimalist you know those president and
vice-president Melbourne Nicodemus we
wouldn't all of a sudden be like right
now people can only wear loin cloths or
togas yes you can't go into debt I mean
it wouldn't be that type of extreme
version of it but I think there are some
practices that Josh and I have in our
lives that other minimalist have in
their lives
that totally would bring about good
effects for the country when it comes to
spending money intentionally now if you
can get everyone to agree on one
intentionality means when it comes to
spending money like that would be that's
the most difficult part right well it
seems to me and Kim I don't know if you
agree with this but it seems to me the
government's role and this will first
sound like a libertarian position but I
don't think it is it sounds to me the
government's role is to function where
the market is inadequate and and I think
at first you're like well the the
libertarians would say you know the
market solves almost everything but also
I think even a communist would say the
government should function where the
market is inadequate they just think the
market is completely inadequate and I
think we are somewhere in between we
actually advocate as minimalist for for
balance you know we are not hoarders but
we're also not Spartans where we have to
get rid of everything and continue to
get rid of everything it's about finding
the appropriate balance it happens to be
that the appropriate balance is usually
far less than what we we thought we
needed as individuals but I actually
it's probably a little bit different in
government and so there is there's a
place for regulation there is a place
for government there is a place for the
market though right
right I mean for me personally you know
I'm more I I'm not a libertarian but I
definitely have a lot of libertarian
esque Ness to me where I'm very into I
die like my freedoms and I like less
government for sure but the socialist
side of me which I'm very I'm really
into the Scandinavian model is to have
that government that works really
efficiently so even if it is seemingly a
I don't even consider the scandinavian
model necessarily a big government i
think that is a minimalist government in
a lot of ways there's not a lot of red
tape there's not a lot of bureaucracy
that you have to get through it's that
they've maintained a very efficient
government so you can't have a
minimalist style government being
libertarian or being even socialist you
know there are actual there's examples
of this you could even say communism
could be I mean when you look at China
it's fairly minimalist sure even running
in a communist style I mean they don't
have any red tape they don't have any
bureaucracy right yeah it's it's it's
Thorat Arianism and and and so I I mean
well it's a lot of authoritarianism but
at least you're not dealing with a big
gut you know you're dealing with maybe a
powerful government yeah well I think
Christie's question ultimately comes
down to she's talking about government
spending here and I would love to see
something and I hear there are a few
countries that do this I believe
Australia Australia is a country that
does this where when you submit your
taxes which by the way are much more
simple and the one thing that's not
minimalist is our tax code and and none
of us understand it I mean we have to
pay a ridiculous amount of money to an
accountant and a bookkeeper just to make
sure that we can give the government the
correct amount of money right now
whereas it places like Australia not
only not only do they do that for you
from my understanding but you get to
understand also where your money is
going and it would be really fascinating
if you could vote directly now we're not
a democracy
and but it would be really fascinating
if we could say you know what I'm paying
$1,000 in taxes
this month and I want this much much to
go to Wars and I want this much to go
toward the homeless that I want
Wow that would be so great get to choose
where your dollars go yeah and then we
would really be voting for what are we
what do we value as a society what do we
where do we want our money to go and I
think it would be such an interesting
test case gosh I almost want to kind of
create that like get a thousand people
and make a sheet and say okay where
would you put your tax dollars and see
where that budget would end up you know
what do people ultimately value yeah
what's the favor if you're watching this
on YouTube just in the comments below
let us know the three things you'd like
your money to go toward the most you're
paying taxes right now this doesn't have
to be in America only about half of our
audiences in the United States but if
you if you say I really wanted to go X Y
or Z and give us percentages yeah yeah
because you just put three it's because
it's not gonna be 33% 33% yeah 33 100%
of my money to go for tanks need more
you always say that you know you brought
up Scandinavian countries and I wonder a
piece of me wonders if socialism works
well because of the community of people
there or is it because of the government
or maybe it's a little bit of both I'm
just curious like what would what do you
think I think it's both I well I think
actually governments are a reflection of
the people and the values of the people
so if you've got a country like Italy
for example which I spent quite a bit of
time there about a year and a half ago
the you know you know I love Italy I
love I love the Italian people but the
average Italian is slightly corrupt like
just in their everyday life by part of
their culture right so if you you know
you talk to an Italian they're kind of
they're they're sort of wheeling and
dealing with you like Matthew Vella so
then that attitude kind of goes into the
government so if they think they can
kind of get a little bit of a deal out
of you then you know if they're if
they've been become an elected official
then they kind of have that same
attitude and I think the in Scandinavia
there's a an attitude and just a culture
of honesty and trust that and a lack of
corruption just in the average everyday
like Swede for example and so
when they take that they take that
attitude to the government and we see
that here in the United States the
average American typically has a very
what you guys would call like a
maximalist right attitude of just
gaining as many possessions as we
possibly can agree with more stuff right
exactly more money we need to you know
our net worth is where our value comes
from and our amount of things and so we
take that attitude when we get into
office as well and that is okay now here
I'm in a situation where I can maybe
take advantage of this and make a lot
more money and then maybe get more money
from the American people in order to
spend on more things and you know
there's that attitude kind of seeps into
the government so I do think it's more
of the culture that creates the
government so in order to change your
government you have to change your
culture it's also a blended system -
it's not true socialism it's it's very
free market with respect to the
Scandinavian countries my wife is her
family's is Norwegian and I think
there's something you said about that
there's almost like this aggressive
honesty and honestly is not even the
right word but and it's not even
transparency there's like this almost I
don't know moral code it's it's the
opposite of what you were talking about
with respect no offense to Italians
where we're all individuals here there
are plenty of corrupt Swedes and and
Danish and everyone else but but I think
you're saying as a culture that there's
there's something that's different that
then bleeds into the government it's not
the other way around South the
government enforcing a culture onto
people we all know that doesn't work you
can't enforce a culture culture is is
something that is sort of organic and
and so when I'm thinking about about
these different styles of government
quite often what works is what works the
same thing that works in our lives
it's a blend it's never going to be
perfectly libertarian or perfectly
socialist that they're there there are a
bunch of different factors that sort of
work together to make it work well yeah
balance is key for sure when it comes to
government and you know I really
appreciate having both sides you know in
the United States I mean of course I
would like more even more you know
political parties I want more political
parties not fewer
but definitely about you know I
appreciate that there's a bit of a push
in a poll that kind of dropped you know
when we go too far one way you've got
another side saying hey wait a minute we
need to go and pull back a little bit
and go more in this other direction but
yeah I mean definitely when it comes to
we we do have to change our attitudes
and what we're looking for out of our
government when you look at our country
you know we're very we're like a hyper
militant country in general right so we
people are good people really love their
guns people really you know that's a
that's an American mentality that
obviously we've taken into our
government we have an enormous military
that is going around the world
now bullying everybody yeah and that is
that's a very American attitude
unfortunately and so how do we get that
to change is the big question how do we
get people to realize what is the what
is more valuable in life and where we
should be focusing our government and
our attention and our time rather than
on all of this that's not that sounds
like some questions that a minimalist
when Iced ask themselves like an extreme
well hey Christie I think the best place
to start with respect to finances is not
with the government it's probably with
your own finances so I'm gonna send you
a copy of our book essential it's an
essay collection with 12 different areas
of intentional living one of those areas
is getting intentional with your
finances so there's a whole chapter in
there about finances so if you like our
podcast you'll like the audiobook
version of essential or if you want the
book book or the ebook podcast John will
be happy to send you one of those as
well
our next question is from Jeremy in
Georgia I've heard you talk several
times about a little bit about politics
I know it's not a subject that's touched
on a lot but I was wondering are you
guys libertarian and if so you know how
how do you fall in line politically I
know you guys don't like labels but what
exactly would you consider yourself or
what do you think would be more of a
minimalistic position on politics was
just thinking what you thought of
libertarianism Jeremie libertarianism no
I am a pest
garyun no I so Kim this is a fascinating
question because people often want to
say hey what box do you put yourselves
in here's what I can tell you is I find
it to be dangerous I don't put myself a
particular box and that's not a cop-out
and let me explain why because I think
it's so much more nuanced than that I'll
give you an example Ryan and I and the
last presidential election voted for two
different people and it's like how could
you two be best friends since you were
fifth graders people we doesn't ready to
see muzzle like I can't listen to
anymore knowing that one of you voted
for Trump we're like wait a minute you
know there is more than two people to
vote to vote for right right and that's
the thing you were just saying a moment
ago you wish there were more than two
parties can you expand on that yeah I
mean we do have some third party options
right there is the Libertarian Party and
there's also the Green Party and there's
a new party emerging called the People's
Party okay but he wigs back of the day
bringing back right we're not really set
up to be necessarily a two-party system
we can actually function with more
parties yes back when Lincoln was
elected people don't realize this but
there was actually four major candidates
and Lincoln won via the electoral
college he didn't get the popular vote
he won through the electoral college
because it was split four ways and so it
just came down to that it you know we
definitely could add more parties the
problem we've got right now is you know
everybody's had to join in to these two
and it's so difficult then to put
yourself in a box when there's the the
fiscal side of things the policy side of
things and then there's the morality
side of things and the fiscal side has
seemed to kind of merge into almost one
party they're not really giving us very
many options with the two in a lot of in
a lot of aspects it's like Oh Democrat a
Republican it's one or the same and now
it's really the differentiation and
seems to be on the moral side you know
how do you morally fit in are you a
Democrat or a Republican in that respect
but we definitely have more nuance and
you know people ask me all the time
what am i a mile ibut arian am i a
progressive I identify myself as a
progressive but I'll tell you a lot of
progress
tell me I'm not a progressive they call
me a right-winger oh wow lots of them
what's fascinating about that is I see
the same thing happen with people who
are libertarians you know when someone
you know during we were listen to them
to the question from Jeremy podcast Sean
was talking about Justin Amash who is
running I think for the libertarian
candidate okay so he's the first
libertarian in Congress and and and what
they'll what I guess
true libertarians will say is you're not
libertarian enough right or or if it's
conservatives you're not conservative
enough or if it's progressive you're not
progressive enough and and the problem
with this we had Pete Buddha judge on
here and he was talking about purity
tests and how when we we can't even meet
our own purity test that becomes a real
problem and that's why I have I have I
have problems with sort of ideologies
because when you create just these two
boxes which box do you fit and it's like
well I fit into that box maybe twenty
percent of the time and I fit in that
box forty percent of the time I don't
fit in either box another forty percent
of the time what am I supposed to do and
it does feel like I mean to a great
extent I mean it can be different with
this election say but so and most of the
time it feels like okay which which one
do I have to vote for and that's really
unfortunate it very rarely do I get
excited to to vote for someone and I
feel like I feel like I should I should
be excited I should have someone I feel
really good about and I don't mean I
want I'm gonna agree with you 100% of
the issues know what I'm talking about
is I feel really good about that person
as a leader and although we might
disagree on things just like your you
can I I really like your show on YouTube
because I agree with you 30 to 60
percent of the time but I want your
perspective I want to be able to
disagree with you because these are
gonna help me change my opinion or it's
gonna help me solidify my own point of
view yeah yeah I mean you know like for
me I I definitely you know what it comes
to like being a progressive I have like
I said I like the Scandinavian model
I'm a real big fan of Sweden I think
Sweden right now is in particular it's
like the greatest country on Earth I
want to pack my bags and move there if
it
dark half the year in cold but it is
difficult to fit into boxes when you
know as a progressive myself I say okay
I'm really into like Medicare for all
and I like a really solid social
structure or so social safety net for
people but I'm a big believer in my
second Amendment rights and my right for
free speech and my right for you know
freedoms I have a real strong
libertarian streak and that makes people
say well you you're not a progressive
and you're not a real progressive that
if you don't want to get rid of guns
right you know that's that's the purity
test you're talking about and I think we
could flate through things as early you
said America has a real love for guns
you can believe in the Second Amendment
without coveting and loving guns right
and there's a difference there you
you're not walking around she didn't
walk in here with an ar-15 you love
people use guns the opposite never works
no you know it's funny weird I feel like
we were pigeon holed into this two part
two-party system because Josh you
mentioned being excited about a
candidate and I can't think of three
people in the Democratic primary that
people were truly excited about yang
Buddha judge and Sanders none of which
made it to the top so I fail to
understand how we can have these
exciting candidates but for some reason
they don't rise to the top like I don't
know I mean maybe I'm just in this
bubble and I am not aware of why one of
those three didn't at least you know
didn't get to the to the finish line
good I do want to talk about I think
we'll save it for the maximum well I do
want to talk about Biden and Trump and
and and we need a more private space
talk about that so fair enough
so I do want I do want to get to that I
also want to talk about Sanders and some
of the the really good things but also
some of the problems that he stumbled
into during that camp so the other thing
I'm thinking about the reason why we're
kind of pigeon-holed into it as well is
that you can't really register as an
independent voter in a lot of states if
you register as an independent voter you
don't you don't get about you get a
ballot but it doesn't have right or left
candidates on there it's like maybe you
can write them in is that what it's what
you're supposed to do with an
independent ballot it depends it so each
state has in some states like for
California for example you can request a
party's ballot so for example I'm a
registered independent in the state of
California and this most recent primary
I requested the Democrat ballot write a
democratic ballot as opposed to the
Republican ballot now you could request
one or the other some states don't lie
you have to be registered member of the
party in order to vote for the in--it's
but only in the primates like that yeah
and I can actually understand arguments
for both sides absolutely if I am a a
Republican why do I want Democrats
voting in my sort of primary but then
again
shouldn't we all have the right to vote
like I see both sides yeah anyway um
Jeremy I want to talk about one quick
thing and I need to move on to the
lightning round here but I think altima
when it comes down to here with whether
it's me or Ryan or camera or anyone else
that I associate with we're gonna have
different beliefs and we have to be able
to accept the fact that we're going to
have different beliefs if not you're
going to experience a lot of discontent
in your life and however you probably
have similar values and so even though
like I said Kim and I we agree thirty to
sixty percent of the time but I think
our values are gonna be very similar
especially our core values and that's
what's really important and then our
values change from there we have sort of
structural values and foundational
values etc and so I would encourage you
to get really clear on what your values
are we have a worksheet on our website
it's free you can download it just go to
the minimalists comm slash V and you can
download the values worksheet you can
sort of identify what your values are
and I would encourage you to review that
with someone that you know because once
you understand who you are it helps you
better understand and express yourself
with others without being outraged that
this is absolutely right because when I
think about how I vote it's I look at
what I value first and then I look at
the candidates I'm like okay who's gonna
support those values and it could go
either way and it and it has for the you
know past several elections not just the
presidential election right right yeah
all right Jeremy thank you so much for
your question check out the values
worksheet we'll put a link to that in
the show notes as well Ryan what time is
it you know time and is it it's time for
the lightning round where we answer
questions from well your text messages
text your questions and comments to nine
three seven two zero two four six five
four yes indeed those texts literally go
to both of our phones which is a lot of
fun and sometimes it sends me a bunch of
eggplant emoji
we would do reply to as many text as we
can even when it's not on the show
during the lightning round Kim this is
where Ryan and I and our guest we do our
best to answer questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text of these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so
people can copy and share our pith the
answers on social media if they like and
you can find all of our minimal Maxim's
in one place minimum or maximum com
really we can just ramble on a bit till
we get something pithy or not we could
just ramble on in general Ryan Laura's
got a question for us how can we avoid
fatigue and maintain civility as
citizens in this heated political
climate well here I'll give you a pithy
answer maybe we'll unpack it together
here my pithy answer is a tribe unites
against a common enemy but a community
unites around a common calls amen so I
think right now we have a lot of
tribalism where it's just like I am with
you because we hate the same people and
well that that bond doesn't last very
long because it all of a sudden you do
something you don't pass my next purity
test now I hate you Kim and and it's
like but if we're part of a community
we're united around something that all
of a sudden it's it it means okay you
know what we don't agree on this this
and this but we have something we can
unite around do you agree with this yeah
I well it just it's the problem is I
think people what they're uniting around
are them are the morality arguments and
so that's where it gets really really
challenging it's not so much about
uniting over a cause or uniting over you
know when it gets really personal
because it's morals and it's about well
you know I'm if you don't agree with me
then you're just an immoral person how
do you even recover from that right
that's the challenge yeah yeah and I
think quite often that that is many ways
that's almost the tribalism that I'm
talking about here because if even if
it's a moral stance we're in in PI wet
by the way in a little bit were gonna
talk about some things on the maximal
like guns and abortion and a lot of fun
things and we can talk about and and I
want to do it as an illustration because
I want to prove that you can have these
conversations that are difficult
conversations without hating someone
else and maybe even disagree with
someone
and and still say well hey I still like
you as a person right and even even when
these topics come up these what we call
them third rail topics like we're just
terrified to touch on on any of these
it's almost like we need more safe
spaces when I mean by that is spaces
where we can say like Ryan and I if
we're just in this room alone there's
literally is not a thing that he and I
couldn't talk about right anything name
the topic we could talk about it yeah
and I think we need to make more room
maybe compassion for for other people's
points of view yeah if you could just
get past the because you have that
viewpoint you're now a bad person yeah
and if you can't get past that then
that's you know but if you can if you
can actually sit there and say okay we
can I can fundamentally believe that
you're not a bad person just because you
disagree with me on something I'm not
gonna automatically call you a racist or
you know a baby killer or something
that's like really awful and that's you
know that's it that's a real challenging
space that we're in right now is is that
ascribing the morality to the person and
then trying to look past that yeah not
very many people can do that right now
it's interesting how I feel like people
are motivated to vote based upon what
they hate it's not about what they love
it's almost like I hate this person so
I'm gonna vote against them and that's
that's unfortunate my pithy answer is
this political affiliation doesn't
matter as much as how you treat the
people around you isn't that funny
because you can say I'm a Christian or a
Jew or a Muslim or a Republican or a
Democrat or a pescetarian mm-hmm right
and that tells me something about you
but it doesn't tell me about you yeah
but you know we talked earlier about
changing the culture and like that's
really how you get a good change in
government and that's to me is how you
change the culture is it starts with how
do you what do you do for your community
what do you do for your friends and your
family your neighbor like that is that's
really the only thing we have control
over like it doesn't matter who the
president is what matters is how you and
I treat each other and if we could focus
on that that's going to cut through all
of this morality policing in this fake
outrage I feel like I think it probably
does matter who the present
but it also doesn't matter as much as we
pretend it does quite often sure and and
and I think well I mean especially like
I think about certain political
candidates I'm not gonna like sit here
and get biased but there are political
candidates that are currently in power
running for running for different
positions that are divisive like their
whole campaign is to divide and if that
is if that's what you support well then
you're being part of that divisive nasai
feel like Kim you I mean you do a
political show on YouTube and so you
turn off your YouTube comments or I
think actually I've changed my stance on
this recently I think that's healthy and
here's why because I think for the
longest time I didn't have the calluses
necessary to sort of handle the the the
feedback and the criticism yeah and I
couldn't and because of that I couldn't
differentiate between the two criticism
just presents a problem screw you you
suck you whatever yeah I hate the way
that your outfit looks whatever it might
be like it's not helpful feedback is
really helpful in fact if I pretend I'm
never gonna look at any comments or
anything that's going to be a different
problem because then it's like me and
the sort of ivory tower thing but you're
saying you read comments because you do
get some feedback that might help you
challenge your own opinion yeah I mean I
definitely learned from my comments
quite a bit you know so I like to read
them I like to see what they even the
really trashing negative comments that
seem to have no value sometimes have
some kind of value yeah like your
earrings that's the level I want to get
well I think I think that's I think
that's healthy and it means that you're
a strong person to be able to to handle
that because firstly it's so when you
first start working out and like your
hands really hurt because you don't have
the calluses right yeah you need the the
sort of cop the internet calluses as
well it took me three years though I
will say when I was doing a talk radio
show and I did radio for a really long
time
and I would get emails like hundreds of
emails every day and so many of them
were hate mail mm and it took me a solid
three years from when I first started in
radio to read those comments and the the
emails and and try to
detach from them emotionally and to not
let that not to allow my energy to
absorb that negativity yeah so for me
then when I moved on to YouTube and
doing my political show I'd been 10
years on radio of getting all kinds of
hate mail and I still get even emails
today that are pretty hateful but I
don't you know that stuff doesn't really
bother me I just I like to hear what
people have to say even if it's really
ridiculous it's still getting inside
their mind a little bit yeah I love that
I wonder what it is about the human
condition where well it reminds me the
New Yorker cartoon that you brought on a
while back there is this gentleman on a
stage hit a thought bubble going on he
was like he was just ending his
performance there's a crowd of people in
front of him and they're all giving him
a standing ovation except for one guy
who's sitting down he's got his arms
crossed and the thought-bubble says I
did horrible I said they all hate me oh
yeah they all hate me yeah so it's like
I don't what is that it's like one
person can ruin your day
until you build up those calluses yeah I
mean I don't seek the criticism but I
will look at comments but sometimes like
I will start reading comments and I got
to stop because I'm like oh what I'm
like really destroying my day right now
if I keep reading I think the difference
is like feedback so what I'll do is
looking for the feedback I'll go to like
our patreon comments for example these
are like the 5,000 most fervent
supporters of ours right and so these
are the P it's not the you know several
hundred thousand of people who listen to
the podcast it's like these five
thousand people who have jumped over at
least some hoop to get there and they're
a bit more understanding they also give
us more room but they also give us
better feedback totally agree with that
yeah and so sometimes there's like this
this barrier of entry or this threshold
where you can go seek feedback just like
right now we're finishing our our fourth
book and it's like I working with two
editors on the book well three if you
count Sean who was a phenomenal copy
editor and and these people are giving
like really scathing feedback and it's
hard it's hard to deal with but I'd
rather get it from them these
professionals then hey Twitter what do
you think about my new book it's
simultaneously the worst and the best
I don't know all right we got a bunch
more to talk about before we get into
our added value segment and our listener
tips today let's say we had a bunch more
surprise questions this week like how
what a minimalist president behave and
we're gonna read some mean political
tweets so speaking of Twitter and we're
gonna talk about a bunch of hot-button
issues like climate change and health
care and Donald Trump and Joe Biden and
abortion and guns and more with Kim
Iverson if you want to hear that check
out our maximal episodes on the
minimalist private podcast it's just a
couple bucks and it's the most honest
way for this podcast to earn an income
because we don't believe in
advertisements you know we think
advertisements suck so we make money
only if you find value in and support
what we create head on over to the
minimalists com slash support to
subscribe and get your personal links so
that our private podcast plays in your
favorite podcast app Ryan what else you
got for us this week I got some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners check them out hi Josh Sherman
this is Bianca speaking I'm calling from
the Netherlands I have a tip for Ryan
and his double swimming trunk dilemma
and a travel tip in general I hope Ryan
told us he didn't like packing an extra
set of swimming trunks just in case the
first one got dirty on the trip
personally I am as you use dr. Bronner's
all-one castile soap I have to add that
I have no way shape or form affiliated
with this company
dr. Bronner sells a pure castile liquid
soap which can be used for over 18
different purposes you can use this to
clean your face body hair dishes laundry
the whole shebang so while you're
traveling you'll only need this soap and
Ryan you can hand wash your swimming
trunks I also love this company for
using organic and certified Fairtrade
ingredients plus their kitchen
recyclable bottles I really like their
philosophy on how to treat the earth and
their suppliers I think this will appeal
to many fellow minimalists I hadn't
heard a recommendation on dr. Bronner so
before so I hope this will help some of
you out there hi my name is Taylor and
I'm from Tampa Florida I was listening
to the Nostalgia episode and as someone
who's a younger
minimalist I don't have a whole lot of
things necessarily but I did have a lot
of t-shirts that I had accumulated from
high school and also from college events
and they all do trigger a lot of great
memories for me but they were really
clogging up my closet and so from the
transition after college I actually took
all of the t-shirts and cut them up and
made a no sew blanket so I suggest that
anyone who has a lot of t-shirts that
would be a useful way for them to get a
use out of them it's a great size it's
small I can travel with it when I go
across the state or when I get on just
keep all those little things that might
trigger nostalgia about an event you
went to or about maybe a club you joined
without having the extra bulk all right
y'all thanks again to Kim Iverson for
joining us today check her out on
YouTube we'll put a link to her show in
the show notes Kim thank you so much and
real quick for right here right now this
is one thing that's going on the life of
the minimalist hot off the presses Ryan
yeah you can't change the people around
you but you can change the people around
you isn't that isn't that applicable for
for politics as well if you're
surrounded by a bunch of people were you
like I really hate their values then
maybe it's time to surround yourself
with people who who have similar values
to you so we have this little reminder
oh it's the most beautiful wallpaper
we've ever put together we have six or
seven of them on our website right now
it's you can't change the people around
you but you can change the people around
you wallpaper you can find that over at
the minimalists comm slash change people
you can find all of our other free
wallpapers on our resource page as well
you can download that for free for your
smartphone or for your desktop you can
follow the minimalists on facebook
twitter and instagram at the minimalist
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast email a
voice memo to podcast at the minimalists
com comment on this episode youtube.com
slash the minimalist if you want our
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at the minimalists comm
you'll also receive our simple Sunday
emails each week for added value this
week I know I said I was gonna stop
playing songs Shawn but don't yell at me
we're gonna play a song this week the
last one
it's it's so appropriate yeah I'm afraid
of getting kicked off of iTunes because
we played music all the time
we don't do it on on YouTube but Jordan
maybe put a link to this video it's so
so good in the guys from our hometown I
seen this video a while ago it's called
my vote don't count oh yeah I answered
that one so it's a rapper named yellow
pain and he's from Dayton Ohio and it is
such a great song cuz he talks it but he
goes into it like a screw these
politicians my vote doesn't count and
then midway through the song he talks
about why that's sort of the attitude a
lot of us have and he talks about why
your vote actually does count and it is
such a phenomenal song I'm actually
trying to get him on the podcast so
that'll be great we can talk I'm curious
like what music do you listen to I
listen to everything I'm actually a jazz
drummer oh okay yeah awesome that's what
I studied all through school very cool
what's your illy what's your like
favorite jazz album and just do you have
one I'm asking for myself really you
know I like trying to like jazz I
pretend I like jazz but I haven't
listened to enough of it
I you know I just would say one of the
standards I mean I I really like burning
for buddy which is a focused job um but
I'm gonna check it out
yeah it's like a lot of awesome drumming
on on that one but you know you got your
basics like Miles Davis kind of blue
yeah I'm gonna train person Coltrane
citrate Chet Baker I mean there's a lot
of great jazz artists out there
you got any drumming videos on YouTube I
don't oh man I know I'd say I think jazz
musicians probably have like some of the
most talent in the musician world
totally agree I went to I went to Ottawa
audio engineering school this is back in
the 90s and what people are still record
on real the real so everything I learned
is completely out of date at this point
because I'll be done on our laptops for
sure but I was like you know dealing
with these eight dads and reel-to-reel
and these giant 128 channel mixing
boards and anyway I recorded this jazz
trio from Ohio State and they as a side
price so they were in there like they're
polo shirts on like tucked into their
khakis and the jazz drummer and it was
this great trio and then they had a side
project for school there was a death
metal band and and so they if they had
extra time to record the
would record their death metal songs and
and it's amazing how it takes the you
know this precision you actually don't
understand how most of us don't
understand these how how much competence
is required to play death metal yeah
which is shocking to me I just thought
it was noise right make a bunch of noise
and scream into the microphone right
it's really talented noise though yeah
anyway this is not noise
check out my vote don't count by yellow
pain it's a single and I think you're
really gonna enjoy it if you leave here
today with just one message we hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
thanks again Kim minimus